hello welcome to the CEO playing w I am
a revenger I thought that she would play
the Kings engine somehow and now we got
a Slav okay that's a very early caption
hmm can i play F or maybe let's try that
f4 and then e for further for the full
center its aggressive but also a bit
risky Queen Anne I'd be 6 I have to go
Quinn d3 I guess ok it's really a big
center so you can um cannot expect to
just grab a big piece of the center and
have no without any any troubles let's
say yeah probably wanted to cover you
forward a little bit a little bit more
yeah longer if we have to cancel long
and otherwise I don't see where I'm
going on my king p5 maybe beehive no t5
oh yeah I thought the file should be
pretty ok isn't this good for white yeah
that's good for why this position I'm
threatening only six now what is black
stones now g5 are played d6 Bishop takes
Bishop seat or something like that after
that such as a loop that is just good
for white maybe Knight b6
sure Queen B 5 seems fine for me but not
as clear yeah here Knight takes I was
thinking just grabbing that huge host
there with the night yeah so what is the
idea I mean here Castle this rope deform
or e 5 you're 5 is also good for Queenie
form
yeah so Luke g4 or back come on I mean
black has to go Bishop d8 now yeah let's
let's play the the obvious moves let's
say and hope that that it works out b5 I
can play Queen B 5 and it doesn't really
strike me as being a problem so take
stakes and e5 for Luke g6 or Queenie
form
OOP takes 26 is that already threatened
probably but Queenie fries also pretty
pretty good now can almost pre-move up
g6 here there's really no way to prevent
that no cats don't no way so and here
ruchi aids and can't meet now c5 was
really a big mistake I think after that
black has huge problems black resigns
yeah the line now is just straight
forward check checkmate or chicks and
then made on a jade I think really the
problem was here black is certainly okay
I mean black black structures completely
sound there's nothing weakened or so and
she must be ok but then c5 and now after
d5 it feels difficult what does black
supposed to do now yeah the computer
actually finds a move with long castles
yeah that's good that's the only one
brilliant I didn't think about that yeah
that strong tinks and now Knight b6 a
saving the day this is an important nope
an important trick roop tix and ce4 very
nice and black is fine yeah she has to
do that it's probably the only move yeah
and black seems to be somewhat okay ya
hear this I mean ok quindi 5 is the
engine move but this is not bad pusher
page form here
yeah it's hard to believe that leg
should survive this the engine gives be
five or eight Queen a six really whining
for that trade of Queens and this is
probably not possible to stand mistakes
you have plus 11 and it's a pretty
strong evaluation plus 14 now if you
give it some time it probably shows them
made yeah plus 15 yeah anyway this is
made now yeah it's unavoidable made
according to stop fishing yeah and this
is just one of them mates yeah c5 was
mistimed here by black it doesn't didn't
seem to be too totally bad just but long
Cassilis then the only moving if you are
reduced to only moves can hang a Trekkie
okay well thanks for watching